[Musique]
à
françaises français en tant que
président de mon département
je visitais ya quelques heures un foyer
d'enfants abandonnés et en croisant le
regard de détresse je me disais au fond
une société qu'il tient debout site une
société qui met au premier plan
l'éducation dans la famille le respect
d'autrui le respect des plus anciens et
puis tout ce qui tourne autour de la
famille les médecins de famille la
responsabilité personnelle tout ce qui
fait une société chaude une société
chaleureuse je suis mère de famille de
quatre enfants il ya quelques années
j'ai fait le choix d'élever mes enfants
malheureusement le statut de mère au
foyer n'est pas reconnu à ce jour
c'est pourquoi je souhaiterais le
salaire parental
qu'en pensez vous et que comptez vous
faire et bien moi je propose le salaire
familial et plus généralement une grande
politique familiale grande politique de
justice familiale une nouvelle politique
de justice familiale avec le salaire
familial pour les familles qui ont des
enfants ou qui choisissent de le garder
au domicile au foyer le grand père la
grand-mère face ou l'éducation ces
échanges de regards entre l'expérience d
un enthousiasme des plus jeunes
il faut aussi parler de la retraite des
mères de famille de manière qui est un
véritable statut familial et qu'on
reconnaisse la mission de service public
de l'éducation
c'est de cette manière que tournant la
société vers les plus petits car les
plus anciens on recréera une
civilisation du respect d'autrui
tourné vers la vie tournait à l'avenir
[Musique]
en tant qu'ancien combattant nous avons
rendu de nombreux services à la nation
et aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas
reconnus à propos de cette retraite
je suis inquiet qui va payer notre
retraite et celle de nos enfants
ben justement je voudrais dire une chose
très simple ce qui peut pas y avoir de
retraite décente s'il n'y a pas de mains
des enfants c'est-à-dire des actifs
cotisants c'est à dire une grande
politique familiale c'est simple mais
encore faut-il le répéter
moi je veux une retraite décente pour
les anciens combattants parce qu'ils ont
mérité de la patrie c'est une question
de justice
une retraite équitable pour les artisans
pour les commerçants pour les
agriculteurs souvent ils ont une
retraite inférieure au rmi ch
et puis il faut penser au maintien à
domicile moi je propose la location
dépendance c'est-à-dire la possibilité
pour les personnes âgées de rester le
plus longtemps possible à leur domicile
en créant notamment des postes 10000
postes d'infirmières libérales en
mettant fin à un certain nombre de
gaspillage de la sécurité sociale la
première qualité d'une société c'est le
respect des plus anciens d'entre nous
[Musique]
en tant que médecin ce qui me préoccupe
c'est que sous couvert de vouloir
juguler les déficits de la sécurité
sociale
nous sommes amenés à porter un énorme
préjudice à la qualité des soins dans le
patient va être le premier à en subir
les conséquences
nous avons encore en france aujourd'hui
le meilleur système de santé du monde
il est menacé par la bureaucratie nous
avons encore un haut niveau de
protection sociale
il est menacée par bruxelles alors moi
je ne veux pas que bruxelles que les
bureaucrates les technocrates se
comporte avec les médecins comme ils
sont comportés avec les paysans des
quotas laitiers les quotas qui touche à
la liberté de prescription médicale moi
je suis attaché à la liberté de la
médecine libérale
c'est à dire la liberté les médecins il
faut faire confiance aux médecins et si
on veut sauver le système de protection
sociale le système de santé
il faut faire des économies moi je veux
rendre la sécurité sociale aux français
rendent la sécurité sociale aux assurés
sociaux pour contrôler les dépenses et
taxer les importations sauvages des pays
qui n'ont pas de protection sociale si
nous voulons demain avoir encore une
protection sociale il faut accepter un
minimum de protection économique
[Musique]
à
si je suis élu président la république
j'oserais faire ce que personne n'a osé
faire
je mettrai au pas des technocrates de
bruxelles
je leur expliquerai que la france compte
en faire respecter la liberté du peuple
français pour protéger nos emplois et
pour garantir notre liberté de décision
dans notre vie quotidienne
je suis agriculteur depuis 31 ans il ya
trois ans la communauté européenne ou
donner des subventions pour planter les
pommiers aujourd'hui on nous enlevait
subventions pour les arracher tout cela
n'est que le résultat des accords du
gatt 1 620 mille hectares sont arrachées
ces vingt dix emplois supprimés en
contrepartie nous recevoir 6 hamilton le
pam en provenance du chili d'argentine à
l'afrique du sud il y a quelques jours
dans le tarn et garonne un spectacle de
désolation
regardez cette pomme elle provient d'un
pommier du tarn et garonne qui a été
arrachée sur ordre des technocrates de
bruxelles que 25 militaires en europe
alors que le même pommier avaient été
plantés avec des subventions sera hors
de bruxelles
alors je suis allé à la grande surface à
quatre kilomètres de l'endroit où ce
premier avait été arrachée je
m'attendais à trouver des pommes du tarn
et garonne et qu'est ce que j'ai trouvé
cette pomme sur les étagères c'est à
dire une pomme en provenance du chili
en d'autres termes nous arrachons en
europe ni aux premiers et nous importons
nos pommes depuis le chili l'afrique du
sud où l'argentine c'est à dire que nous
marchons sur la tête c'est la même chose
pour les ordinateurs c'est la même chose
pour les hélicoptères c'est la même
chose pour les chaussures etc etc
alors moi je veux un agriculteur demain
qui vivent non pas des primes mais de
son travail
les américains remettent leurs jachères
en culture moi je veux qu'on fasse la
même chose qu'on établisse la préférence
européenne c'est à dire que les
consommateurs européens consomment les
produits qui sont fabriqués chez nous en
europe par nos entreprises par les
salariés des entreprises européennes si
on fait ça le pays repart le pays revers
shi
[Musique]
je m'appelle christian patrons pêcheurs
artisans depuis quelques années nous
sommes confrontés à des rentrées de
poissons de pays tiers sur notre marché
on a l'impression d'être gouvernés par
des technocrates du parlement européen
et à cause de cela c'est la mort du
métier de pêcheur artisanal et de tous
les métiers artisans de france
encore un exemple typique du chômage
provoquée par le désordre européen avec
un salaire français vous pouvez payer
aujourd'hui 60 à castanet 80 philippe
donc toutes frontières ouvertes on peut
pas lutter c'est vrai dans toutes les
industries de main d'oeuvre c'est vrai
dans les services dans les transports
arrière etc
moi je propose de taxer les importations
sauvages des pays à très bas salaires et
qui n'ont pas de protection sociale si
on veut maintenir chez nous les acquis
de civilisation la protection sociale il
faut un minimum de protection économique
[Musique]
je chasse depuis l'âge de 16 ans de
chasse pour mon plaisir
nous sommes les premiers protecteurs de
la nature
on comprend mal les directives de
bruxelles qui nous impose des lois soit
disant que nous sommes pas capables de
gérer notre cheptel
alors que de nous-mêmes l'an passé nous
avons arrêté la chasse au lièvre pour en
favoriser le repeuplement ce chasseur
est certainement beaucoup plus efficaces
pour la protection de la nature et de
nos traditions régionales que n'importe
quel technocrates de bruxelles
moi je propose non plus un pouvoir qui
s'éloigne mais au contraire un pouvoir
qu'il soit proche des gens proches de
toutes nos préoccupations quotidiennes
il faut que les français soient libres
tout simplement il faut que la france et
c'est la grande question soit une nation
léman
[Musique]
l'urgence c'est de sortir la france du
socialisme
je suis le seul dans la majorité a
proposé la protection européenne de nos
emplois et la réduction des dépenses des
administrations
l'urgence est de retrouver le sens des
valeurs quand j'entends parler de
distribuer des seringues des jeunes de
15 ans je dis ça suffit
la démagogie je suis le seul à proposer
de lutter contre la corruption et la
drogue pour moi la vie la famille
doivent être protégés contre toutes les
cultures de violence alors la gauche
vous le sentez bien là cette fois ci
aucune chance de l'emporter
vous pouvez donc choisir au premier tour
le candidat de vos convictions
aidez moi à donner un maximum de poids à
nos idées pour que le prochain président
de la république fasse une politique de
droite et non de gauche fasse une
politique de la france
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mes chers compatriotes chacun d'entre
nous ressent au quotidien que la vie est
de plus en plus cher le travail de plus
en plus rares l'insécurité de plus en
plus forte et que le communautarisme
menace l'unité de la république depuis
vingt ans les partis politiques au
pouvoir démantèle nos protections à
succès nos entreprises abandonnent la
transmission des repères et valeurs de
la société
c'est ainsi que notre pays a perdu peu à
peu la maîtrise de son territoire de ses
lois et de ses libertés
au point que les français ne croient
plus en la politique n'est en l'avenir
mais demain avec le patriotisme
je veux rendre l'espoir aux français
identité nationale marseillaise drapeau
tricolore maîtrise de l'immigration
protection européenne
tout au long de cette campagne les
candidats sont venus se positionner les
uns après les autres sur les thèmes que
philippe de villiers défend depuis tant
d'années à l'heure de faire votre choix
ce ne sont pas les paroles et les
promesses qui compte mais la certitude
que celui pour lequel nous allons voter
respectera ses engagements
comme beaucoup d'entre vous en 2002 j'ai
cru que la majorité élue dont je faisais
partie allait mettre tous ses pouvoirs
pour aller au bout des réformes dont
notre pays a besoin
député à l'assemblée nationale j'ai
défendu avec conviction une vraie
politique de droite
malheureusement je me suis bien vite
senti seul j'ai par exemple essayer de
mettre fin au droit exorbitant accordé
aux clandestins comme l'aide médicale
d'état ce milliard d'euros que nous
dépensons chaque année pour les frais de
santé des étrangers en situation
irrégulière
quand les français comme les étrangers
en situation régulière doivent payer le
ticket modérateur ce droit injuste
bénéficie à 200 mille clandestins
malheureusement et malgré les
engagements de la campagne
je n'ai pas été suivi je pensais aussi
que nous avons le droit de dire que
l'islam doit s'adapter à la république
et non pas la république à l'islam
mais lorsque nicolas sarkozy a annoncé
la création du conseil français du culte
musulman
j'ai compris que la logique
communautariste l'avait emporté comme
beaucoup d'entre vous je me suis encore
senti trahi quand j'ai vu ma famille
politique renoncer à abolir les 35
heures
défendre la discrimination positive
plutôt que le mérite
le mariage homosexuel plutôt que la
famille cette fois ci comme vous je ne
veux pas de déception
comment croire ce qu'ils promettent pour
demain ce qu'ils n'ont pas pu ou pas su
faire quand ils avaient le pouvoir
devant tant de contradictions on
recherche une ligne droite cette ligne
c'est philippe de villiers qui
l'incarnent
ces réussites locales la cohérence de
ses idées auxquelles il est toujours
resté fidèle son projet offensif pour
que nous retrouvions ensemble la fierté
d'être français prouve sa sincérité et
sa capacité à agir
votez philippe de villiers c'est la
garantie d'une droite qui ne pliera mis
devant la gauche ni devant la rue
aujourd'hui le vrai vote utile pour la
droite c'est le choix de la droite
patriotique de gouvernement c'est le
choix de philippe de villiers en temps
le président du conseil général de
l'aborder j'ai agi à contre-courant des
politiques menées au niveau national
j'ai fait de la vendée une terre de
réussite
les résultats sont là au classement de
tous les palmarès la vendée fait la
course en tête
fort de cette réussite est convaincu que
les grandes choses se font avec le coeur
je me présente à vous comme l'homme du
patriotisme
parce que le patriotisme apparaît comme
la seule réponse face aux problèmes
majeurs de notre pays qui doit
impérativement retrouver la maîtrise de
son avenir
je ne suis pas un politicien
contrairement à tant d'autres
par tempérament et par expérience je
suis un créateur un entrepreneur un
bâtisseur
je vous propose d'élargir demain
l'expérience de la réussite vendéenne à
l'échelle de toute la france pour moi le
pouvoir
n'est pas un bien de consommation c'est
un service le service des français et de
la france que j'aime c'est pourquoi fort
de la cohérence de mes convictions je
sollicite votre confiance
[Musique]